when you did your interview with sarah
palin
i thought more people would praise you i
think that was one of the single best
interviews i've ever seen anywhere sarah
palin i when i watch that thing and i've
watched it probably 50 times to me it's
a lesson on how to interview someone
well i you know actually that interview
did get a lot of praise and support i
think that later when she talked about
it publicly
um it was more criticized but when
initially when it when it aired howard
it got um
i didn't get much criticism criticism at
all even from republicans i think most
people thought it was
incredibly fair
and
that i didn't sand back her that the
questions were not gotcha questions they
were basically questions in my mind that
required accumulated knowledge and a
bill an ability to be a critical thinker
when you prepared to interview sarah
palin did you go in with the attitude
that this is not a bright woman no you
know what i went in with the attitude as
that that there was a lot that was not
known about her how she would govern
right what her opinion was on certain
policy issues how she felt i mean she
had just gone to the un and met with all
these world leaders i wanted to know her
take on foreign policy issues
on iran nuclear weapons i mean i i
really
really approached it as i would have
approached any political candidate who
was not that well known do you know you
have gold or do you were you shocked by
the reaction you know i thought that
people who did not like her did not
support her would would feel that even
more strongly that they would dislike
her more and i thought that people who
supported her would basically
blame me for the questions i asked and
excuse anything that she did during the
course of that interview so i thought it
would is that the way it played out no
how did anyone vote for her afterwards i
think what happened was there was this
sort of swath of undecided voters kind
of more moderate voters who are really
on the fence and if you remember at that
moment in time during the campaign
uh the trajectory for obama was kind of
flatlining a little bit sarah palin had
given this riveting i mean she did an
incredible job at the convention because
she was like
a politician the likes of which nobody
had ever seen before it was an amazing
performance yeah i mean she was so
accessible and funny and um you know she
was an incredibly appealing candidate so
do you think you were i'm not going to
say totally responsible but somewhat
responsible for obama winning
no i would i i would say that that i
think for this as this broad swath of
undecided voters i think they saw this
interview they thought gee this is the
person who's going to be a heartbeat
away from the presidency so i think it
really gave people pause and they
thought um yeah i think it changed a lot
of people's opinion when i saw the
answer to the periodicals you know
what's so interesting that whole
question about what do you read that was
kind of an afterthought for me because
that was at the end of our second
interview it was a ridiculous easy we
had done one interview in new york and
then we did a second one in ohio after a
campaign appearance and i was curious
because when anyone is so extreme in
their political ideology i'm always
curious like what made them that way
what shaped them what did they have a
formative experience was it their
parents what what do they read that kind
of helps reinforce that on a daily basis
it was a throwaway it was like hey what
do you read when you wake up in the
morning it was it was i think she was so
aggravated with me by that point that
she just was very defensive about it and
she said you know people in alaska read
and i said you know i thought
i wasn't suggesting that but i thought
it was interesting and i wonder if she
and her own mind has gone back and
thought gee maybe i should have said i
read every newspaper in alaska because
i'm governor of that state or i read
every national newspaper and you know
katie i google things i mean i don't
know